[Musica]
sono sicuro che se ci chiedessero di
spiegare il significato della parola
innovazione ciascuno di noi
istintivamente penserebbe a qualcosa che
ha che fare con la tecnologia
un'innovazione cos'è lo dice la parola è
una cosa nuova
più evoluta più moderna più aggiornata
rispetto ad una versione precedente
poi è qualcosa di nuovo anzi se lo
vediamo di che tutta quando utilizziamo
il sostantivo innovazione noi mettiamo
subito dopo anche l'aggettivo
tecnologica innovazione tecnologica le
innovazioni tecnologiche cioè come se
questa cosa nuova più aggiornata più
moderna possa esistere soltanto si è
creata all'interno di un ecosistema
tecnologico
siccome io davo in una grande azienda di
telecomunicazioni quando penso alla
tecnologia la prima cosa che mi viene in
mente anche seguendo il dibattito di
questi mesi
quest'ultimo anno mi viene in mente la
telefonia cellulare
allora siccome tendenzialmente quando si
diventa grandi ci si dimentica di ciò
che si ha quando si legga piccoli
io direi facciamogli epilogo delle
puntate precedenti
nel 1982 è nata la telefonia e cellulari
il primo gsm oggi sta per i generazione
prima generazione di telefoni cosa si
faceva con un cellulare nelle 82 si
parlava e basta e se vi ricordate
costava è mica poco dieci anni dopo ci
accorgiamo che il telefono sapeva anche
scrivere e nel 1992 con il 2g nasce la
sms rivoluzione pazzesca ma qui eravamo
ancora all'alba 2001 3g che i giochi si
fanno seri sul serio è proprio una roba
quando il gioco si fa duro videochiamate
mms prime rudimentali navigazioni su
internet molto rudimentali però insomma
si iniziava 4g 2012
il salto è compiuto ed epoche in cui
viviamo oggi viviamo nei telefonini o
film partite messaggistica istantanea
siamo proprio immersi nei nostri
cellulari e domani il 5 g cosa deciderà
il 5 g beh sostanzialmente tre cose una
larghezza di banda maggiore ossia dieci
volte in più la quantità di dati che
possiamo scaricare oggi una velocità 10
volte maggiore è una latenza
zero sapete così della latenza lo dico a
quelli che hanno i capelli un po di
luigi lui miei anche più grandicelli
partite di calcio anni 70 80
vedevamo il pallone passare da cabrini e
scirea erano i partiti intercontinentali
la voce del telecronista grava 4 secondi
dopo aver visto quell immagine vi
ricordate quella è la latenza c'è la
differenziata è l'input output latenza a
zero significa simultaneità immaginate
da tecnologie di precisione o per la
microchirurgia quanto è importante
lavorare in simultaneità invece che in
latenza e nel mondo adesso ci sono
strizzi reality di telefonini device di
pc tutti connessi tutti in velocità
treni aerei ponti gallerie non si capiva
niente della tecnologia abilitante di
questo mondo meraviglioso e il 5 g che
abiliterà a quella cosa che noi
chiamiamo internet of things l'internet
delle cose che poi non è nient'altro che
la possibilità di questi apparecchi
elettronici di dialogare in 3d d'oro
quando si parla di innovazione
tendenzialmente chi ha i capelli un po
grigi come i miei che cosa fa
manda avanti i più giovani come volpi
vecchie che mandano quelle giovani ad
annusare un po la capite che se ci sono
tagliole e diffidente andata usare i
ragazzi invece molto più smart che noi
li utilizzano
e questa tecnologia cosa fa inverte un
paradigma il paradigma
dell'apprendimento sono i più piccoli
che diventano i professori dei più
grandi no
i più giovani che insegnano agli adulti
ad utilizzare la tecnologia i nipoti che
prendono per mano i nonni e le aiuto ad
attraversare questa strada fatta di chip
di touch screen di roba più o meno
incomprensibile ma siccome l'innovazione
la roba veramente importante come tutte
le cose importanti si scatenano dispute
ideologiche di tutti i limiti avete in
un modo chi avete un altro anche sulla
parola stessa
beh c'è chi vede l'innovazione con un
approccio che si chiama crescita
esponenziale è perché sempio la
telefonia cellulare il classico esempio
1g e 2g 3g sempre cresce come un albero
da frutta io l'ho pianto nel terreno
pole il nascere utilizzo e shell
hydrogen media mangia il frutto mi
rimane un seme loro pianto feltri
germogli ha scelto tutti all'infinito
per uscire esponenziale
oppure secondo approccio che si chiama
innovazione combinatoria cioè ci sono
quei pensatori che ritengo che
l'innovazione non sia nient'altro che
una cosa già disponibile con delle cose
esistenti
per esempio con i mattoncini e le
costruzioni da solo non è nulla né
pagando cento e faccino astronavi una
casa eccetera eccetera
l'esempio più classico per capire questo
approccio è l'auto che si guida da sola
2012 non faccio il nome ma tutti
pensiamo a quella cosa lì ma quella di
nuovo cosa c'è pensiamoci un attimo
nulla l'automobile esiste da 120 anni
il gps da una quarantina più o meno i
radio comandi basta pensare alle
macchinine perché i nostri figli amici
da quando esistono almeno 40 50 è così
ma è l'assemblamento e la combinazione
quegli elementi che ha determinato un
nuovo prodotto quindi innovazioni
combinatori ecco devo dire io però oggi
dopo proporvi un alternativa e quindi
dimenticate tutto quello che vi ho detto
sull'innovazione perché oggi voglio
parlarvi di una innovazione che pone al
centro di se stesse il più straordinario
elemento che esiste in natura
questo l'uomo che il nostro antenato
siamo noi sono quelli che verranno dopo
di noi e mettendo l'uomo al centro di
questa cosa che si chiama innovazione
parlando di innovazione in una
prospettiva antropologica cosa significa
fare innovazione significa cercare il
senso delle cose perché l'uomo è l'unico
animale dotato di quella caratteristica
che gli americani chiamano consciousness
consapevolezza la traduzione non è
perfetta ma rende bene l'idea
la consapevolezza siamo gli unici in un
giorno sanno purtroppo che dovranno
morire
siamo gli unici animali che compio e le
scelte sulla base della logica e della
razionalità e non solo assecondando
l'istinto quindi fare innovazione se
seguiamo questa strada topologica
significa anche domandarsi cosa può fare
un se comando per produrre un
cambiamento in una realtà che si
presenta altamente complessa un
professore iniziatici caro negli anni 80
dal nome impronunciabile si chiamava
mikhail sexten semiali propositi suoi
studenti un modello bellissimo e disse
immaginate che la vostra casa stia
bruciando
e voi avete solo 30 secondi per prendere
un oggetto e portarlo via
cosa prendete a parte quelli che hanno
lasciato la suocera tra le fiamme
quello che è venuto fuori è che
l'oggetto che i ragazzi prendevano e che
lui a raccontare un libro meraviglioso
che si trovava proprio il senso delle
cose the meaning of things
eva che non era mai l'oggetto che aveva
più valore ma era l'oggetto che aveva
più senso non era mai l'oggetto più
costoso è un oggetto più importante
e allora se questo è vero e proprio vero
che fa l'innovazione quindi fare una
scelta che ci porta un cambiamento passa
attraverso la ricerca di senso e questo
rappresenta un vero salto con il passato
mi piace questa definizione perché se
pensate fino a 15 anni fa nelle grandi
organizzazioni nelle grandi aziende fine
anche negli istituti di ricerca fare
innovazione cosa significava sta intorno
a un tavolo 15 vendite che le persone
più o meno al buio come in questa sala
si discuteva poi a uno veniva un'idea si
accendeva la lampadina si accendeva la
luce la killer application quella che
ammazza tutte le altre certo poi
bisognava implementarla e si produceva e
si faceva innovazione beh ma oggi è così
siamo alle porte del 2020 abbiamo un
problema di idee e cioè fare innovazione
il tema dell'innovazione ha come
questione centrale trovare nuove idee
siamo inondati di idee cioè di lampadine
accese ne abbiamo milioni basta
accendere un telefonino da mattina alla
televisione il giornale andare su quelle
piattaforme promosse dalle stesse
aziende che chiedono agli utenti
mi aiuti e implementare il mio prodotto
miliardi di idee
noi abbiamo il problema opposto abbiamo
il problema di capire qual è la
direzione che dobbiamo seguire cioè non
c'è un tema di creatività ma c'è un tema
di senso dove andare di significato
nelle scelte che dobbiamo compiere
possiamo dire che siamo al buio perché
c'è troppa luce troppe lampadine accese
e non capiamo quella è la direzione
giusta
e allora come facciamo a capire questa
direzione come facciamo a coglierla
e questo vale nelle nostre relazioni
personali professionali privati in tutti
i contesti
beh se abbandoniamo lo stereotipo che
fare innovazione significhi trovare
qualcosa che e fuori di noi semmai
attraverso l'ausilio di qualche
apparecchio elettronico nelle nostre
mani che si chiama cellulare o telefono
o tablet o quant'altro per passare
invece al paradigma che a fare la
differenza e introdurre cambiamenti sono
gli esseri umani sono le persone che
propongono modelli di novità all'interno
di un mondo altamente complessa perché
dentro di noi e non fuori di noi gli
alberghi
coi più grandi agenti di cambiamento e
di innovazione che esistono il cuore il
cervello sono il cuore il cervello che
combinandosi tra di loro dando vita a
quell insieme di sensazioni di emozioni
e di legami complessi che nessun
cellulare o computer potranno mai
raggiungere il cervello e il cuore hanno
reso l'uomo il luogo dei più grandi
cambiamenti l'uomo questo essere
selvaggio e il nostro antenato qualche
milione di anni fa migliaia e migliaia
di anni fa viveva in una catena che
mangiava il cibo crudo eravamo noi nei
tempi della storia 10.000 15.000 20.000
anni significa ieri eravamo noi avere i
nostri stessi geni e un giorno
quest'uomo decide di uscire da quella
caverna e si unisce in un altro uomo
scambiandosi sensazioni ed emozioni e
decidendo di dare un pezzo di se stesso
agli altri e mette insieme quella cosa
che oggi forse chiameremo famiglia o
comunità affettiva e che glieli neanche
se avevamo sapevamo definire uscente da
quella capelli né legandosi ad altri
uomini ha creato una palafitta e poi un
villaggio e poi un paese programma e
trovo che poi ma che poi un uomo sulla
luna
e così con l'amore ea più grande
innovazione ma inventata straordinaria
atto quinto scena terza come e giulietta
sono a teatro ci provo come dite come è
andata e qui io fissa il mio sempiterno
riposo e scooter o da questa carne
stanca del mondo
il gioco delle belle se stelle occhi
guardatela per l'ultima volta braccia
prendete il vostro ultimo abbraccio e
voi labbra voi che siete la porta del
respiro suggellate con leale bacio un
patto con la morte che tutto capisce
ragazzi questa è l'innovazione più
straordinaria che c'è e che ci sarà
sempre
adesso non voglio dire che
necessariamente con scambio di
sensazioni di sentimenti di emozioni di
produrre degli effetti positivi per
esempio ce n'è uno pessimo che si chiama
matrimonio tipicamente 250 anni è fatto
di fasi diverse la prima 22 anni
straordinaria passione amore progetti
video con una seconda fase dura 48 anni
è insomma c'è mia moglie ne guardato
male
quello che voglio dire che io non amo i
futurologi no quelli che dicono che
l'uomo fatto che cento anni sarà alto 2
metri e 70 voleva sbattendo
le mani eccetera perché è un mestiere
molto comodo che il futurologo nota
nessuno di noi ci sarà di chi guarda
avevo detto a maria di cose che non si
tengono però sono certo che diciamo
partendo dall'assunto del vecchio saggio
che dice che donò ogni cambiamento
rappresenta un progresso ma che ogni
progresso passa per un cambiamento
sono assolutamente certo che ci saranno
sempre un cuore e un cervello ad
indicare all'uomo di domani una strada
una strada che ha un senso profondo e
che farà sentire tutti noi
già oggi orgogliosi di essere parte di
questa straordinaria comunità che si
chiama umanità
[Applauso]